hello internet and welcome to this
course
all about open telemetry in this
course i'm going to be showing you how
you can get
full stack observability on the
performance and behavior of your
software project
by using an open telemetry with your
analysis tool
of choice if you want to be able to tell
why your project or app is running too
slow is broken or you just want to
improve its code
quality this is the video for you but
first
what exactly do we mean by open
telemetry
well let's start off with the name
itself
we have open so like open source
and telemetry which is an institute
collection of measurements or other data
at remote points
and their automatic transmission to
receiving equipment for
monitoring the word telemetry
actually comes from the greek root word
teller or remote
and metron for measure and that's
exactly what we are going to be doing
we are going to be facilitating a way to
measure the performance of
everything we use in our app remotely
with any app when you want to start
looking at this kind of data
you have two parts that need to come
together the first
is figuring out how to generate and
transmit that data
and then the second part is deciding
what you are going to do
with that data so in other words how are
you going to
analyze it open telemetry deals with
that
first part up until now there has been
no real standardized way of describing
what your system is doing
this is down to the fact that we all
like to think differently use different
programming languages different machines
in a combination of different ways this
was a problem
especially for those wanting to build
observability tools
at the heart of open telemetry project
is exactly that
a standardization for describing what
distributed systems are doing
no matter what programming language or
computer systems you are using
today the open telemetry project can be
described as a collection of tools
apis and sdks used to instrument
generate collect and export telemetry
data
so that we can analyze it later on with
whatever platform we wish
by standardizing our data it means we
are not tied to anything in the long run
and it makes moving from one analysis
tool to the next
super easy and will not affect your
historic data
as i mentioned at the beginning this is
an open source project it is made up of
many many developers and their input
if we have a look at github here for the
project you will see it is super
transparent
you can see the governance committee you
can see the technical committee
if you are interested in getting
involved please do join their mailing
list and attend their community meetings
you can even see all the meetings that
you are welcome to join
before we get started though i just want
to go into
a little bit of what we're going to
learn on this course
so let's break it down okay so
in this course first we're going to look
at what are micro services
followed by what is observability then
we're going to look at
melt followed by the history of open
telemetry
then we're going to actually start by
setting up our project
we are then going to talk about tracing
distributed tracing and context and
propagation
before adding tracing into our project
we will then move on to looking at
metrics before
finally ending on our distributed
projects
i will end this course with where to go
next
we expect our website apps and online
services to load
almost instantaneously right think of
the frustration some of us feel when
websites take more than two seconds
to load on the back end a feat of
engineering is needed to keep a global
system running to make sure
that you have access to netflix or
instagram
only a tap away let's have a look at
netflix for a minute
netflix at its peak consumes 37
of internet bandwidth in the us there
are thousands of people
clicking play at the same time with
activity peaking in the evening
though as a global platform it's a
constant
peak the challenge is how to run a
service with zero loss
while processing over 400 billion events
daily and 17 gigabyte per second
during peak in today's video we will
dive deeper
into what types of systems power these
amazing
services and how we can use data to get
deeper visibility into the insides of
these complex
systems
historically developers have built
applications in monoliths with
large complex code bases a single
monolith will contain all the code for
all the business activities an
application performed
this is all fine and dandy if you have a
small app but
what happens if your application turns
out to be successful
users will like it and begin to depend
on it traffic increases dramatically
and almost inevitably user requests
improvements and additional features
so more developers are roped into work
on the growing
application before too long your
application becomes a big ball of mud
a situation where no single developer
understands the entirety
of the application your once simple
application has now become
larger complex multiple independent
development teams are simultaneously
working
on the same code base and simultaneously
changing the same
sections of code then it becomes
virtually impossible
to know who is working on what code
changes collide code quality suffers
it becomes harder and harder for
individual development teams to make
changes
without having to calculate what the
impact will be
to other teams and teams can lose sight
of how their code might be incompatible
with others
among other issues this generally
results in
slower less reliable applications not to
mention
longer and longer development schedules
in
come microservices the main principle
behind a microservice architecture is
that the applications are simpler to
build and maintain
when broken down into smaller pieces
when using microservices you isolate
software functionality into multiple
independent modules that are
individually responsible for performing
precisely defined
standalone tasks these modules
communicate with each other through
simple apis microservice architectures
let you
split applications into distinct
independent services
each managed by different teams it leads
to
naturally delegating the
responsibilities for building highly
scaled applications
allowing work to be done independently
on individual services without
impacting the work of other developers
in other groups
working on the same overall application
however trying to get visibility into
this system can be very difficult
when you have hundreds of services and
applications your requests
travel through debugging and
troubleshooting can
be a nightmare this is where open
telemetry
comes in as we already touched on
telemetry is defined as the science or
process
of collecting information about objects
that are far away
and sending the information somewhere
electronically now
observability means how well you can
understand
what is going on internally in a system
based on its outputs
especially as systems become more
distributed and complex
it's hard to see what is going on inside
your application and why things may be
going wrong
when talking about observability we need
to define the data types necessary to
understand the performance and health of
our application
broadly metrics events
logs and traces melt metrics
are measurements collected at regular
intervals
most have a timestamp a name one or more
numeric values and a count
of how many events are represented these
include
error rate response time or output
an event is a discrete action happening
at any moment in time
take a vending machine for instance an
event could be the moment when a user
makes a purchase from the machine
adding metadata to events makes them
much more powerful
with the vending machine example we
could add additional attributes such as
item category and payment type this
allows questions to be asked
such as how much money was made from
each item category
or what is the most common payment type
used
logs come directly from your app
exporting detailed data and detailed
context around an event
so engineers can recreate what happened
millisecond by
millisecond you have probably logged
something when you use things like
system out print or console log
traces follow a request from the initial
request
to the returned output it records the
casual chains of events to determine
relationships between different entities
tracers are very valuable for
highlighting inefficiencies
bottlenecks and roadblocks in the user
experience as they can be used to show
the end-to-end latency of individual
cores
in a distributed architecture however
getting that data is very difficult you
would have to manually instrument
every single service one by one layer by
layer
this would take as much time as writing
the code itself
which is annoying luckily there are some
awesome open source projects as well as
companies that make this
a lot easier
in 2016 open tracing was released as a
cncf
project focused only around distributed
tracing because the libraries were
lightweight and simple it could be used
to fit any use case
while it made it easy to instrument data
it made it hard to instrument
software that was shipped as binaries
without a lot of manual engineering work
in 2018 a similar project called
opencensus was open source
out of google which supported both the
capturing retracing information and
metrics
while it made it easier to get telemetry
data from software that was shipped as
binaries
like kubernetes and databases it made it
hard to use the api to instrument custom
implementations
not part of the default use case both
projects were aiming to make
observability easy for modern
applications
and expedite wide adoption of
distributed tracing by the software
industry
however developers had to choose between
two options with pros and cons
it turns out that the approaches of the
two projects were complementary
rather than contradictory there was no
reason why we couldn't have
both the abstract vendor neutral api and
a well supported default implementation
in late 2019 the two projects merged to
form
open telemetry this brought forward the
idea of having a single standard for
observability instead of two
competing standards
okay so first things first let's go a
bit meta and understand exactly what is
going to happen
in order for us to view what is
happening
in our app here we have our
project think of our project as a
project we have made with our code
editors of choice for example if we run
it
it runs locally on our machines let's
also say this project is built to listen
out for
requests so like listening out for a get
request for example we have decided that
we want to
measure our app's performance based on
the requests
that it makes to do this the first step
as we mentioned at the start
would be to implement open telemetry
into the project
we are doing this to help us standardize
the data
once we have implemented open telemetry
and standardize the data
we need to think about what we are going
to do with the data
how we're going to view it and so on for
this we can use an analysis tool
by analysis tool i mean any type of tool
that gives you observability we are
going to look at a few of these tools
one that focuses specifically on tracing
one that focuses specifically on metrics
and one that looks at everything in one
platform
we are then going to send our data to
our analysis tool
of choice here we have an example of
what our data can
look like in a tracing app such as
zipkin
a metrics app such as prometheus and an
observability tool
such as new relic that will give us an
overview of everything
as well as other more bespoke insights
in one platform
we will go into each of these in their
dedicated sections
let's start with implementing open
telemetry first
okay so before we start the only
prerequisite
i am going to ask of you is that you
have docker downloaded onto your machine
docker is a container platform for rapid
app micro services development and
delivery
and if you don't know much about
containers and micro services
just stick with me for now i have a
section dedicated to both of these
topics
coming up after this section for those
of you that don't have it
please navigate to the docker website
and follow the instructions
in order to get set up i personally
would choose to download the docker
desktop
as i am working on a mac i choose the
mac
option once you are done make sure your
docker desktop is
running on a mac i would simply hover
over the icon
like so you will see if you open up the
platform
i currently have no containers running
having a container is going to be
important for when we get to using the
analysis tools
such as a tracing backend like zipkin
once we have all got docker up and
running let's
get going let's get our terminal up
now i'm going to navigate to a folder
where i like to store all my projects
it's called development please go ahead
and choose
any directory that you would like to
work in
now once here using the macdurr command
i'm going to make a folder for the new
project i'm about to start
i'm going to call it open telemetry
starting out
please be aware that if you are using a
different terminal
other commands may need to be used now
let's go into the project using the
command cd
the first thing i'm going to do is start
a container
so it's ready for the next section so
as mentioned the first thing that you
need before you can start collecting
traces
is a tracing back end like zipkin that
you can export
traces to to set up zipkin
as quickly as possible run the latest
docker zipkin container
exposing port 9411
if you can't or don't want to run a
docker container
you could also choose to download zipkin
directly
so just so you know that is an option
too
if you want to explore that option more
i would suggest visiting the zipkin
website
so this is the command to run our
container
and there we go we now have this
container id
it has worked next up we need to get a
package.json file in our project
we can do so by typing npm init
having a package json file will make it
easier for others to manage and install
all the packages we need for the project
if you are getting errors
it could be because you don't have
node.js and npm installed
if that is the case please visit
nodejs.org
in order to get set up with that by
following the download
instructions okay
so we have initialized the utility
i am just going to press enter for all
these fields it's prompting me to answer
so enter enter
enter enter and enter
okay we are done creating our
package.json file for now
if we list out all the files on our
project
using the ls command you will see the
file
right there now finally i need to create
an app.js file
so a javascript file and put that in the
project 2.
some of you might have a different
approach to adding files to a project so
that is totally up to
you however you'd like to create that
file but once we are done
we now need to open up our project as i
am using vs code i'm going to use the
command
code dot in order to open up our project
and there we go there
is a folder with an app.js file
and a package.json file
you will see the package.json file has
all the prompts we were asked
as i skipped all the prompts it's just
the standard default entries
or no entries at all if you go to the
app.js file
you will also see that it's currently
empty it has nothing in it
okay so the first thing i need to do is
change this
to point to the app.js file we created
not the index.js as there is no index.js
file
and just for fun this is not necessary
i'm going to fill out the description of
my project so
open telemetry course
the next thing i want to do is just add
a start script
so for this script i'm going to run
node app js okay
now for the fun part let's get to adding
some
packages to start using open telemetry
we are going to need to install some of
its packages
using npmi or install for short
i'm going to install the open telemetry
core package
the open telemetry node package
open telemetry plug-in http
open telemetry plug-in https
open telemetry exporter zipkin to get us
ready for the next section
and open telemetry tracing for the next
section too
and express the only non open telemetry
one
okay so we need all of those to install
okay and great so these are looking good
so if we look back here here are all the
packages that we just installed
they have automatically populated our
package.json file
so this is looking good we have just
missed one so let's go back and use
npmi or install for short and install
open telemetry plug-in express
and we are done okay now
let's move on to our app.js file the
first thing i'm going to do
is define a port for us so const
port process env
port or a string of port
8080 next
up we are going to need express
so const express
and express is one of the packages we
installed so
this one right here so we need to tell
our file that this const requires
express
we are then going to call express and
store it as the const
app the first thing i want to do is just
get a message in our console log to let
us know all is good and that we are
listening out
and on which port so just as a recap
what i am doing here
is getting the app to start a server
and then with this code i'm getting it
to listen
out to our defined port for any
requests okay next up i'm going to paste
this
super basic piece of code
this code is an example of a very basic
route routing refers to how an
application's
end points respond to client requests we
have defined the route using methods of
the express app
object that corresponds to http methods
for example app get handles get requests
these routing methods specify a callback
function
called when the application receives a
request to the specified route and http
method
in other words it listens out for
requests that match specified routes and
methods
in this case the route is our home page
we essentially want to trace every
single time a get
request is made to the home page we will
do this in the next
section
now that we have the basic installation
done it is now time for us to talk about
tracing
so as we know open telemetry allows us
to essentially standardize our data
the next part is actually viewing the
data in a way that we can analyze what
is happening behind the scenes
we will do this with a tracing system in
software engineering tracing involves a
specialized use of logging
to record information about programs
execution
this information is typically used by
programmers to debug by using the
information contained in a trace log
to diagnose any problems that might
arise with a particular software or app
distributed tracing however also called
distributed request
tracing is a method used to debug and
monitor applications
built using a micro service architecture
distributed tracing helps pinpoint where
failures occur and what causes poor
performance
so as we can now see being able to get
tracing
data telemetry is pretty important to
the overall performance of an app
however as we discussed in the
introduction due to systems using all
types of different languages frameworks
and infrastructures
it's a hard thing to do without some
sort of common approach
that's why open telemetry can help so
much with distributed tracing
by providing a common set of apis sdks
and wire protocols
it gives organizations a single
well-supported integration service for
end-to-end distributed tracing telemetry
for this course the tracer we're going
to be using is called
zipkin zipkin is a distributed tracing
system that helps gather timing data
needed to troubleshoot latency problems
in service architectures zipperkin was
originally created by twitter
and is currently run by the open zipkin
volunteer organization
i am using zipkin for no other reason
than i had to pick one but please
do feel free to choose any back-end
tracing system
that you wish the choice is completely
up to you
in general once the traces are
implemented into applications they are
said to record
timing and metadata about operations
that take place
an example of this is when a web server
records
exactly when it receives a request and
when it sends a response
this data is usually represented by a
bar just like this
and goes by the official name of spam so
in this example we have two services and
a bunch of spams
to explain this imagine this represents
your favorite food delivery app
so imagine you make an order right now a
few things will happen
each represented by a spam you send
information back and forth from services
in order to make the payment
find a delivery driver closest to you
and notify that driver with your order
each of these operations generates a
span showing you the work being done to
make this happen
in this case the spans have implicit
relationships so
parent and child but also from
individual services
in the trace as you can see each of the
spans starts at a different point
and takes a different amount of time we
call this
latency and network latency in a
nutshell
latency is the delay between an action
and a response to that action
and network latency refers to specific
delays that take place within a network
latency is generally measured in
milliseconds and is unavoidable due to
the way networks communicate with each
other
it depends on several aspects of a
network and can vary if any of them are
changed
errors on most systems are usually quite
easy to spot
if your bar ends in red or similar for
example you know
that an error has a cut
now it's time for us to look at context
and propagation
these two concepts will allow us to
understand the topic of tracing
a lot better so as we know distributed
tracing allows us to correlate events
across
service boundaries but how do we find
these correlations
for this components in our distributed
system need to be able to collect
store and transfer metadata we refer to
this metadata as
context context is divided into two
types
span context and correlation context
span context represents the data
required for moving trace information
across
boundaries it contains the following
metadata
we have a trace id a span id
the trace flags and the trace
state of the span context
and then we have the correlation context
a correlation context carries
user-defined properties
this is usually things such as customer
id provider's host name
data region and other telemetry that
gives you application specific
performance
insights correlation context is not
required
and components may choose to not carry
or store this information
a context will usually have information
so we can identify the current span and
trace
and propagation is the mechanism we use
to bundle up our context
and transfer it across services
so there we have it context and
propagation together these two concepts
represent the
engine behind distributed tracing
if you would like to learn more about
these two topics and do a deep dive
please visit the urban telemetry website
for the purpose of this tutorial however
a basic
knowledge of births will suffice
so just as a bit of a heads up in this
next section we will go through how to
first initialize a global tracer
and after that initialize and register a
trace
exporter okay so here we are where we
left off
now in the last section we ran the
latest docker zipkin container
exposing port 9411.
if we actually visit localhost 9411
we will see the zipkin ui that comes as
part of doing that
so here we are this is what we are going
to use to view our traces
okay let's carry on
next let's create a file named tracingjs
and add the following code this is just
the sample code provided to us by
opentelemetry
if you visit their website you can see i
am just copying this code right here
and pasting it into my project you will
also see that this file uses
two of the packages we installed in the
initial setup
once we have pasted that we need to
initialize and register a trace exporter
we have already done part of this as we
installed two packages
necessary for this part in the initial
setup section
and that is the open telemetry tracing
and open telemetry exporter zipkin
packages
so first off let's make a new
zipkin exporter so provide add
span processor new simple span
processor this is from the open
telemetry tracing package
as you can see that has shown up at the
top
new zipkin exporter and that also comes
from another package so the open
telemetry
exporter zip can package as you can see
appearing at the top this might not
automatically show up for you
it's just the code editor i'm using so
you might have to type those two
out and then we write service name and
choose a service name
i'm going to put getting started but you
can replace it with your own service
name
okay that is looking good and so is the
app.js
file okay great
all tracing initialization should happen
before your application code runs
the easiest way to do this is to
initialize tracing in a separate file
that is required using the node r option
before your application code runs i will
show you what i mean by this
so now if you run your application with
node
r tracing js and app.js
your application will create and
propagate traces over
so let's run that and now let's send
requests to
application over http we can do so
simply by refreshing the
localhost 8080 page you'll see traces
exported to our tracing backend
that look like this so here you will see
we are making a get request to the home
page
which is responding with hello world and
here we have
getting started as that is what we
called our service name
we also get a start time and a duration
as a span now as you use this more and
more often
some spans might appear to be duplicated
but they are not
this is because some applications can be
both the client
and the server for these requests if
this is the case you will see one span
which is the client side request
timing and one span which is the server
side request
timing anywhere that they don't overlap
is
network time okay now i'm going to show
you
one more example so just to
differentiate i'm going to change my
service name to get
date now i'm going to go into my
app.js file i'm just going to copy this
piece of code right here
and paste now i want to essentially
listen out to
any time a get request is made to the
path
date so in other words if someone right
now went to localhost 8080 forward slash
date that is us making a get request we
will also be able to see
respond with the actual date so
let's go ahead let's go back to our
localhost 8080 and type forward slash
date
oops i stopped my app running let's make
sure it's running
so i'm just going to start this up again
okay
and refresh our page and great
there is our object with today's date
amazing
so now if we visit localhost 9411
so the port we exposed and click run
query we will see all the requests that
have been made
so there we go we can now see our get
date service and at the moment the only
request we have that it's listening out
for
is the get request now i have actually
renamed the service remember so if i
visit the home
page you will see that request is also
being stored under the get
date service name you can tell which one
it is by the time stamp
okay let's move on okay
we are now done with the basic
implementation of tracing
however we are literally just touching
the surface
in the project portion of our course i
will show you
how to use open telemetry to instrument
a distributed system
by this i mean i will show you how to
trace multiple services
and their interactions with each other
if those exist
in this next section we're going to
learn how to collect metrics with open
telemetry and prometheus prometheus is a
monitoring platform that collects
metrics from monitored targets by
scraping metrics http endpoints on these
targets
in this section i will show you how to
install
configure and monitor our first app with
prometheus and open telemetry
we will download install and run
prometheus to expose
time series data on hosts and services
unlike tracing which works in spans
metrics are a numeric representation of
data
measured over intervals of time metrics
can harness the power of mathematical
modeling and prediction
to derive knowledge of the behavior of a
system over intervals of time
in the present and future since numbers
are optimized for storage
processing compression and retrieval
metrics enable longer retention of data
as well as easier querying
this makes metrics perfectly suited to
building dashboards that reflect
historical
trends metrics also allow for gradual
reduction of data resolution
after a certain period of time data can
be aggregated into daily or weekly
frequency let's have a look at this in
action
in this section i'm going to be using
prometheus as my metrics back end
now that we have set up end-to-end
traces we can collect
and export some basic metrics
first i'm going to stop this from
running
let's go to the prometheus download page
and download the latest release of
prometheus for your operating system
as i am using a mac i'm going to click
on this one right here
once that has downloaded open a command
line
and use cd or the command cd
to go into the directory where you
downloaded the prometheus table
in my case it would be the downloads
directory
now i need to untie it into the newly
created directory
make sure that you replace the file name
with your downloaded taba
so don't necessarily use this one and
now
let's go into the directory if i list
out
all the files and folders you will see a
file
named prometheus yamo this is the file
used to configure prometheus for now
just make sure prometheus starts by
running the
dot four slash prometheus binary
in the folder and browse to localhost
9090 okay great
and there is our prometheus user
interface
so you will see this says server is
ready to receive
web requests so that should be all good
i am just going to go ahead and open up
a new tab right here so i can keep that
running
and i'm going to open up our directory
using the vs code
shortcut once we have confirmed that
prometheus has started
we need to replace the contents of the
prometheus yaml file
with the following so literally just
delete
everything and put in this much shorter
piece of code
this will set the scrape interval to
every 15 seconds
we are now ready to monitor our node.js
application
in this next section we need to
initialize the required open telemetry
metrics library
initialize and meter and collect metrics
and initialize and register a metrics
exporter
to do this we are going to have to
install some libraries
we are going to need the open telemetry
metrics package
so let's go ahead and install that let's
navigate back to our project first so
don't do this in the directory we just
downloaded
and in here type npmi
or install open telemetry metrics
great we are now ready to initialize a
meter and collect
metrics we first need a meter
to create and monitor metrics a meter
an open telemetry is the mechanism used
to create and manage
metrics labels and metric exporters
create a file named monitoring.js
so a javascript file in the root of your
folder
and add the following code so we're
going to
need the open telemetry metrics package
for this
cons and we're going to get the meter
provider from it
and by it i mean the open telemetry
metrics
package we are then going to make a new
conso const meter and we're going to use
the
meter provider i'm going to make a new
meter provider
and use get meter as well as i'm just
going to put your beta name for now
we can change this whenever we want
now we can require this file from your
application code and use the meter
to create and manage metrics the
simplest of these metrics is a counter
in this next part we're going to create
and export from our monitoring js file
a middleware function that express can
use to count
all requests made by root
so first off we need to modify our
monitoring js file
so once again i'm just going to copy
this sample code from
open telemetry open source projects in
order to
help us count the requests and
paste that into my monitoring js file
next we need to import and use this
middleware in our application code so
our app.js file
so we need to get count all requests
from our monitoring js file so the
module export we do so by typing
const count all requests
require monitoring js so literally
we are using this right here
now let's get to using it type app use
count all requests and call it now
when you make requests to your service
your meter will count
all the requests perfect
next up let's look at initializing and
registering
a metrics exporter counting metrics is
only useful if you can export them
somewhere where you can see them
for this we're going to use prometheus
creating and registering a metrics
exporter is much like the
tracing exporter above first you need to
install the prometheus exporter by
running the following command
so i'm just going to use npm install
and open telemetry exporter prometheus
next up we need to add some more code to
our monitoring js file
so once again i'm going to copy the code
given to us by open telemetry to get
started
and paste it into my monitoring js file
don't worry i will share this repo with
all of you so that if you do get stuck
you can refer to my finished project
now in a separate tab so just leave this
running
ensure prometheus is running by running
the prometheus binary from
earlier and start your application
we do so by using the script we wrote so
npm start you should see prometheus
scrape endpoint and the http
localhost 94644 metrics
as well as listening for requests on
localhost 8080.
now each time you browse to localhost
8080
you should see hello in your browser and
your metrics and prometheus should
update
you can verify the current metrics by
browsing to localhurst
forward slash metrics which should look
like this
you should also be able to see the
gathered metrics in your prometheus web
ui we can also add more routes in our
app.js file
let's go ahead and do that to see what
that would look like
so i'm just going to add some
pre-written code here and that is a
middle tier root
and another root that has the part
backend
so now we have our date our home page
from the previous
section our backend route now
and a middle tier route as well as a new
home page route i'm also going to need
axios for this so another package that
will help me in making these requests
so let's go ahead and import that into
my project
and nice that is done let's run
npm start okay now let's check
everything is working as expected
the home page now responds with hello
back end this is actually because we
have two
homepage routes so i'm just going to get
rid of the other one in a bit
the end route responds with hello back
end
the date route responds with today's
date
so that looks good so i'm just going to
delete the initial homepage route that
we had that responds with hello world
and keep the new one okay
and now let's visit middle tier and we
get response of
hello back end and finally let's visit
metrics where we get
a request counter of all the routes we
have visited
okay so this looks like it's all working
we've visited all the routes and our
counter seems to be working
fine now let's go ahead and see that in
the prometheus ui
so we're going to have to pick something
to execute
and there we go
now before we move on to our project i
thought let's take a little bit of time
to understand exactly what issues can be
detected
with open telemetry here is just a list
that i'm going to go through with you
starting with the
back end in the back end with open
telemetry you can pick up
bad logic or user input leading to
exceptions being
thrown poorly implemented downstream
calls
so for example to infrastructures like
databases or downstream apis
leading to exceptionally long response
times
or you can pick up poorly performant
code on a single api
leading to exceptional response times
on the front end with open telemetry you
can detect
bad logic or user input leading to
javascript errors
you can also use it to find poorly
implemented javascript
making your ui prohibitively slow
despite performant apis
and you can even use it to locate
geospecific slowness requiring
geo distribution and finally for
infrastructure you can use it to
identify
noisy neighbors running on a host
sapping resources from other apps
configuration changes leading to
performance degeneration
version audits so zero day vulnerability
checks
ensuring config changings went through
or just
misfiguration with your dns making your
apps
inaccessible so that is a list to get
you thinking of
issues that you can detect with open
telemetry
now that we have that covered let's move
on to our project
in this part of the course i want to
show you what
happens when you are building out an app
with a more complicated backend that
deals with
two services it is a hypothetical
project that you can adapt
to anything that you wish it is an app
that gets
movies for your database by the end of
the project
you will be able to trace exactly how we
got the movies
and how long each step took
okay so here is a project i have
pre-made
thanks to the open source community and
inspired by an open telemetry
contributor allen storm
it is a project that has two services
with one
service relying on the other but not the
other way around
in this project i have a main dashboard
service
as well as a movies service which will
return all the movies for
our app the layout of this project
is similar to what we did in the tracing
setup
however instead of having a separate
tracing
js file to trace each service
the code is directly in each file
so as you can see each service
is in the root of our project i'm just
going to minimize
this so we can see the code a little
better now
so from the beginning of our course this
should look familiar
so as a reminder open telemetry requires
that we
instantiate a trace provider configure
that trace provider with an exporter and
install open telemetry plugins to
instrument specific
node modules let's talk through the code
so we can see here as a refresher
especially as it's organized
in a different way than what we saw in
the basic
implementation so first we are going
to get the nodetrace provider from the
open telemetry node
package a trace provider is what will
help us
create traces on node.js
next we will get the console span
exporter
and the simple span processor from the
open telemetry tracing package
and then we need to get the zipkin
exporter from the open telemetry
exporter zipkin package
now that we have what is necessary let's
move on
so at the moment we have made a tracing
program
and to actually generate the spans if
you remember
we installed a plug-in called open
telemetry plug-in
http the nodetrace provider object
is smart enough to notice the presence
of a plug-in
and load it this code creates a trace
provider and adds a span
processor to it the trace processor
requires an exporter so we instantiate
that as well
both are responsible for getting the
telemetry data
out of your service and into another
system
with this code we created an exporter
then use that exporter when creating a
span
processor and then added that span
processor to our trace
provider okay so that is what that code
does
let's actually name our service now i
have
left this blank so let's go ahead and
fill that in
as this service is going to deal with
the main service
i'm just going to call it dashboard
service
here we're instantiating a zipkit
exporter
and then adding it to the trace provider
we of course need to get express from
the package express
and sell a server and listen out on port
3001 for connections
the app is currently not going to
respond with anything for requests any
part
as we haven't written anything yet i
want it
to respond with the dashboard itself and
the movies
from the movie service but before we do
that
we need to build out our movies js file
so this file is exactly the same as the
other file
just perhaps with some code in different
places
and a different port in this
file i want to deal with the movies so
i'm just going to rename this service
name to
movies service if
i ran this service we would be listening
out to port
3000 now i'm going to determine how our
app responds to a get
request to the movies endpoint so i am
just going to write app
get and then i am simply going to put
the movies path so i'm making this
up this is an async function
and i am going to pass through a request
and a response
okay so there we go
and then i'm simply going to type res
type json as a string
and response send jason stringify
and i'm just going to send a movie
object with
let's say an array of movies so let's
put some objects in an array i'm going
to make the array
have movie objects and each movie object
is going to have
a name so a name like
jaws a genre so for example jaws is
a thriller as a string and that is my
first
object and then i'm just going to make a
quick other object
this time let's put a different type of
film so i'm just going to put the
string of annie and once again
let's put a genre so i'm just making the
same movie object just with a different
name and a genre
i'm going to put family and make another
object
i'm going to stop after this one because
this is just for illustration purposes
and let's put jurassic park as the name
and let's put action as the
genre
okay that is it that's our array of
three movie objects
okay now let's run our app
so let's actually go to localhost
3000 and put the movies path
so what i'm doing is i am requesting the
url
and of course our app is going to listen
out for it
and make a trace
so now let's go over to the zip kid ui
and
search for recent traces we will see
we've recorded a single
service trace however if we click
through into the trace details we'll see
these traces do not look like the traces
we've previously seen
in our previous examples one span
equaled one service
however a span is just a span of time
that's related to other spans of time
we can use the span to measure any
individual part of our service as well
the express auto instrumentation plugin
creates spans that measure actions
within the express
framework we can use it to find out how
long each middleware took to execute
how long your express handler took to
execute
and so on it gives you insights not
just into what's going on with the
service as a whole
but also individual parts of your
express system
this is the role most of the contrib
plugins play
in the open telemetry project the core
plugins are concerned with ensuring each
request is bound to a single trace
but the contra plugins will create spans
specific to the behavior of a particular
framework
okay great let's carry on so now that
we've done that
i want to show you how to use open
telemetry to instrument
a distributed system this is what our
dashboard.js file is for i essentially
want my dashboard.js file to call the
movies
service as well so let's get to
writing that code the first thing
i am going to do is actually use the
node fetch library which we haven't
installed yet so this servers use the
nerd fetch library to call our movie
service
let's go ahead and install that so i'm
just going to get my terminal and type
npmi for install
and node batch okay
now once again i'm going to have to type
app
get and then use the root of dashboard
and then write an async function so asic
function and pass through a request and
response now i am
going to right here i need to fetch data
from a second
service and that's the movie service so
i'm just going to write some pseudo code
to remind us of that
fetch data running from second service
and my second service is the movies
service okay
now i am gonna write a function that
will essentially help us
get all the url contact from the movies
service so essentially our object with
the three
movies in an array or movie objects in
an array
so let's get to writing this function
i'm going to write this function
and pass through two parameters so
whenever i pass
through a url into this
function and a fetch
so the fetch is actually going to use
our node fetch library
then i'm going to use these two
parameters to essentially
get the body of that url so i'm going to
use a
promise to do this a new
promise i'm going to pass through
resolve
and reject and then i'm going to use
fetch
to fetch the url and then
whatever is in the body i'm going to
use so fetch url
resolve reject then
rest rest text then
body so
that is my function for getting the url
content let's get to using that
okay i'm just going to actually change
this
uh i don't like the way this is written
and i want to make it consistent with
the
bottom so i'm just going to
change this up so it looks a bit neater
it's just a different way
of writing functions so just so it's
consistent to
that okay
so once again let's go down to the code
i've pre-written
and in here i'm going to fetch data
running from the second server so the
movies
service i am going to actually
save the contents of the url as movies
so
const movies await
and use the function that we pre-wrote
to pass through the url
so the url we want to get the content of
is http
localhost 3000 for slash movies so
there we go there is our url it is the
same url
that i have written here so url url
that's what we have done
and then i'm going to need to require
node
fetch so i'm going to literally write
require
and the package node fetch
i'm going to put res type json
and res send jason stringify
and now i'm going to write the word
dashboard
okay so i'm making an object and i'm
going to write dashboard and then
whatever we've saved
as movies should show up here
so essentially the contents of the url
will show up here
okay so now i can run this file
so i could run this file but we will see
an error
this is because our file relies on the
movie service
being up and running so i'm just going
to show you now i'm going to type
node dashboard.js so it's listening at
localhost
3000 3001 however if i visit
localhost 3001 for slash dashboard
i get an error this is because we need
our movie service to be running
so let's go ahead and make that
true i'm just going to open up a new tab
and type node movies js
okay that is now running and listening
up port local host 3000
so now here's our movies and let's
refresh
or let's rerun the dashboard so once
again
node dashboard js
and then refresh our page amazing
we will see our dashboard object with
the contents of the url
from the forward slash movies path
amazing so this is working fine our code
is working
as it should now let's see
how this looks in our zipkin ui
so i'm just going to rerun the query and
look at our latest
and there we go so once again to
reiterate that
in a nutshell the dashboard service is
dependent on the movie service
to populate it this is true for many
apps you interact with today
and which is why this example is the one
i wanted to show you for our project
now we can see here that each span from
the services are linked together
the open telemetry htt plugin took care
of this for us
the node fetch plugin uses the
underlying functionality of node.js
http and https to make requests
so that's how to instrument an
application using
open telemetry like this is pretty cool
as obviously you can see our dashboard
service
and then you can see exactly uh what
time
it's going to the get movies service
and then coming back
okay that brings us to the end of our
project i hope you've enjoyed this
section
this is of course just the surface of
what you can do with urban telemetry
there is a lot more to it but until you
get the fundamentals i sincerely hope
you can go through this course again
and again until you feel more
comfortable building your own
projects
so far in this project we have directly
gotten data from our app and sent the
data to zipkin
but what happens if we want to try
sending it to another backend to process
our telemetry data
does that mean we would have to
reinstrument our whole app well
the amazing contributors to open
telemetry have come up with a solution
to fix this
the open telemetry collector is a way
for developers to receive
process and export telemetry data to
multiple backends
it supports open source observability
data formats like zipkin
jaeger prometheus or fluentbit
sending it to one or more open source or
commercial
backends in this next section i'm going
to show
you how to use it
okay so for this section in using the
open telemetry collector we're going to
be using new relic
as our observability tool of choice
all i'm going to do is head over to new
relic and
sign up next you'll see some questions
please answer these to the best of your
ability so for example where you store
your data
and just click save your account will
then
be set up once you get to this page
right here i'm just going to ask you
to not interact with anything for now
and head over to
one.newrelic.com
once here i'm going to ask you to go on
the drop down of your profile and click
api keys once here i'm going to ask you
to gravitate to creating a
new key and just select ingest
license i'm going to name this hotel
example
and i'm just going to give it some notes
just so we can keep track of our api
keys and great our api key is now
created let's copy it and move on
the next thing we're going to do is
actually get our open telemetry
collector
for this i'm going to head over to new
relic's github account
in which i can get the open telemetry
examples
so i'm just going to ask you to clone
this repo into your local
machine i have already done this so i'm
just going to go ahead and head over
to that repo now and here it is
once here i'm going to ask you to
navigate to the collector's
nr exporter docker hotel config
yaml file because we're going to have to
change this up a little bit
so please do head over here now and i'm
just going to ask you to add a little
line of code
this line of code will add zipkin as a
receiver
a receiver is a way that data gets into
the open telemetry collector
so because we already have our app
configured to use zipkin we will be
telling the open telemetry collector hey
we will be sending you data in the form
of zipkin
so that is what is happening we are
adding zipkin as a receiver and then
giving it an
endpoint which in this case is 0.0.09411
now because zipkin reports tracing data
we are going to add zipkin
as a tracing receiver underneath service
and that's it the next thing we need to
do
is go over to the docker compose yaml
file
and make sure that the docker container
that runs this open telemetry collector
is actually able to receive the data
through the same port
that it would have if it was zipkin so
we're going to add the port
9411 just like
so and save it
now according to the readme to run this
we need to use the api key we just
created
so in my terminal i'm just going to
export the new relic
api key i just created with this
command next we need to spin up the
docker container with
this command making sure of course that
we are in the correct directory so that
is my fault
let's go into that directory so the nr
exporter docker
and once again we run the docker
container
and wonderful now let's go back to our
movies
dashboard project that we have been
working for in this
course so now i just need to modify our
app ever so slightly to work with the
open telemetry collector
for this to work we need to change two
things
we need to change the url that it is
reporting at
so this one right here i'm simply going
to use
it like so so we need to do this for the
dashboard
and also for the movies service
and that's it now i'm just going to
reinstall the dependencies for those who
are just joining us here and i've taken
this project
from the description below and then
let's run the two services like we have
been doing previously in this
tutorial wonderful
okay now i'm just going to call the
services by visiting the dashboard
service
as a reminder the dashboard service
relies on the movies service
i'm going to call it multiple times so
we can get lots and lots of data to work
with
so maybe just a few more okay done
let's move on now that we have our app
and have successfully instrumented the
open telemetry collector that is
forwarding our data to new relic
we should now be able to visualize our
data for this we need to go to the
explorer tab on new relic and
once here we will see the two services
the
dashboard service and the movies service
just like in the previous distributed
tracing section
let's deep dive further as you can see
in the dashboard service
there was a spike let's find out what
was happening
so it looks like there were 18 traces
with nine spans
and two entities for the dashboard
service
that sounds right great and if we dig
deeper you will see the microservice
that our dashboard service was
communicating with
to actually serve the final result
wonderful
as you can see we can get a lot of
awesome data to do things such as get to
the root cause analysis of what could be
going wrong in your app
check how your micro services are
performing and so
so much more okay and there we have it
that was our open telemetry course
before we finish i just want to take a
moment to recap what we have learnt in
this course
so to recap in this course we learnt how
to
set up the backend for a project then we
learned how to
implement tracing into our project as
well as metrics if we need to
and then we also looked at two services
and how they communicate
thanks to distributed chasing
i hope you now feel comfortable knowing
the benefits of using open telemetry
as well as have a good understanding of
how you would go about implementing it
into your node.js projects if you are
wondering
where to go next with your newfound
knowledge i would suggest learning about
infrastructure monitoring and digital
experience monitoring
these are two other ways to visualize
analyze and troubleshoot your entire
software
stack i will leave you with this and a
link to new relic to find out more and
get a free account with no expiration
date thanks so much again for watching
and i'll see you
soon